[Musik]
hab jetzt schon tag nicht gemeldet ich
befürchte ich dass diesmal recht gut
die statistik spricht gegen das auf die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass der in
abhängigkeit der zeit steigt
exponentiell sich gemeldet und für 24
stunden
dass wir ungefähr genau hier mal was du
machst du hier
[Musik]
ich versuche das perfekte rezept fischer
draußen finden
also natürlich gibt es faktoren die die
kurve prinzipiell nach hinten
verschieben so also todesfall und die
unmöglichkeit
[Musik]
ich muss was wichtig sie besprechen er
mich später dort überlebt kann ich jetzt
nicht fest
du musst bei der richtigen nummer hier
ein trick der ergebnisse und wir wollten
sowieso noch jemand muss statistisch
brauchen wir mit 31 punkten geht
natürlich in den negativen bereich
mehr lebensqualität also ungefähr wurde
bis jetzt nicht unbedingt aufs gute
werke hier kriegt man schon den ganzen
tag noch nichts getrunken habe ich die
treppen theoretische effekt als das
jetzige lotti nur durch jedenfalls die
eigentlich egal ob wir zwei
möglichkeiten ich habe oft an den
tierischen daten aber ungefähr ergibt
sich daraus für die lebensqualität in
abhängigkeit
spinnen essen mehr fleisch als menschen
also eine kleine spinne sorgen mehr
fleisch essen als erster mensch die
gesamtmasse an fleisch in relation wird
zu mir gesagt mache den menschen gesagt
machen wir schwinden
wahrscheinlich jeden fall fahren wir
diesen optimalen punkt 1 schon
überschritten die welt irgendwo hier das
bedeutet wir sollten weniger russen
[Musik]
immer ein bisschen anderes video von uns
mit melanie unserer grafik in
ausnahmsweise mal vor der kamera schaut
euch gefallen und wird von der trug
natürlich will ich wissen wer von euch
ist auch wissenschaftler oder wer von
euch hat wissenschaftler freunde und was
sind eure erfahrungen sind wir bessere
oder schlechtere freunde schreibt in die
kommentare
und wir sehen uns am nächsten donnerstag